Speaker 1: You've heard me talk before about a
sort of colloquial application of what's sometimes
known as Occam's Razor and the way we apply it
colloquially outside of the scientific world
is simpler explanations. All else being equal
are preferable, and we should not come up with
unnecessarily complicated explanations for
things that take place when there are simpler
explanations that are just as good explanations
that require fewer assumptions or fewer
unlikely events. And that is sort of the principle
front and center in the story that I want to take
a look at with you guys. You might remember that
a few months ago, we jokingly said, you know,
when all of the people that are not vaccinated.
Or rather put a different way when so many of
the people that get really sick from COVID are
unvaccinated, we are going to start to hear from
the right, the conspiracy theory that there
is a deliberate effort being made to infect
unvaccinated people, to punish them for not
being vaccinated, which is an overly complicated
explanation. When we have a simpler explanation,
the vaccine protects you from getting sick.
Right? We have a similar situation here. There
was a conspiracy conference and a bunch of
people got COVID. Why? Well, because they were
together indoors, and Covid's really contagious.
And instead of saying, Oh well, we got
COVID from being together and we spread it.
Instead, they came up with the explanation
that it's actually anthrax. It's how how do
you talk sense into someone who believes this?
This is a great vice article explaining it.
And it reads. A group of unvaccinated people who
attended a huge conspiracy conference in Dallas
earlier this month all became sick in the days
after the event, with symptoms like coughing,
shortness of breath fever instead of
blaming the COVID global pandemic.
The conspiracy theorists think they were attacked
with anthrax. This far right conspiracy claim
began after a dozen people spent time together at
the Reawaken America tour. This is that conference
where we've played clips of Alex Jones going to
it, Michael Flynn all sorts of different. I think
Jim Breuer remember when that right wing quote
comedian Jim Breuer pretended to be a bird on
stage going Vouching Foundry, and it was like the
most unfunny clip ever. All of that was it this
reawakened America tour, and we started saying
a year ago or whenever they started this thing,
these are going to be super spreader events.
That's exactly what they became. This was a
particular installment of the Reawaken America
tour in Dallas the weekend of December 10th.
The fact that this was likely a COVID outbreak
and superspreader event has been almost entirely
ignored. James Surowiecki writes on Twitter.
Anthrax symptoms include fever, chest pain,
shortness of breath, cough, headache, fatigue, in
other words. Many of the symptoms of COVID 19. But
the Reawaken America tour features anti-vaxxers
and COVID skeptics, so it'd be embarrassing if a
bunch of people on tour caught COVID. And there
are all of these different posts from people
talking about this is actually anthrax. Let me
see if I can get this one pulled up on the screen.
I spoke with Joe Altman earlier today. It
appears that he, Jovan Hutton, Pulitzer
and a dozen other folks that were present in
the green room at the reawakened America tour
are suffering from symptoms related to
an anthrax attack, an anthrax attack. So
understand the absurdity of this. They have COVID
symptoms. They're all hanging out together indoors
as the wildly contagious Omicron variant spreads.
And they say, Well, we were clearly targeted by
anthrax. Now, anthrax is most common in Central
and South America. Agriculturally, of course,
central and South America are sub-Saharan
Africa, central and southwestern Asia,
southern and eastern Europe. The Caribbean
anthrax is really rare in the United States.
So the explanation that they have identified for
the phenomena of people having all these COVID
symptoms is we were attacked in the green
room by someone who obtained an anthrax,
planted it in the green room and made us all very,
very sick. Now, whether in reality, if you believe
that there was an anthrax attack, you would report
it to authorities. Authorities would investigate.
These things are taken really, really seriously by
law enforcement and we we've even had a couple of
situations. How do I even I don't even know how
I want to say this. We've had situations where.
It was important to verify that there was not
anthrax somewhere and. It's taken very seriously
by law enforcement. Let's just put it that way,
and it's an overly complicated explanation for
you all got COVID because COVID is spreading
like wildfire, it's spreading like wildfire in
Dallas. That's where the event was. You were all
together in an enclosed room. It's Occam's razor.
Is it something really rare to the United
States used as a bioweapon to target you
for your political beliefs? Or is it the
virus that's everywhere? And once again,
as is common with conspiracy theorists going with
the unlikely, far more complicated explanation